Hallo
Herzlich willkommen in unserem schönen Garten.
Darf ich dir meine Familie vorstellen?
Das ist meine Frau.
Ihr Name ist Marit.
Ihr Name ist Marit
Schön dich kennenzulernen.
Ich bin Marit.
Und wie ist dein Name?
Und dieser nette Herr da
drüben am Grill ist mein Mann.
Sein Name ist David.
Sein Name ist David
Und das sind unsere beiden Kinder.
Anna spielt mit ihrem roten Spielzeugauto.
Das Mädchen mit dem Teddybär heisst Lea.
Schau sie dir nur an.
Sind die beiden nicht allerliebst?
Wenn es doch nur immer so wäre.
Und hier ist das neuste Mitglied unserer Familie.
Sein Name ist Balu.
Ist er nicht süss?
Hast du Lust auf eine kleine
Tour rund um das Haus?
Das ist die Vorderseite meines Hauses.
Meinen Garten hast du bereits gesehen.
Ich glaube du hast da etwas
verwechselt mein Lieber.
Wessen Haus ist das?
Bitte entschuldige Liebling.
Natürlich ist es unser Haus.
Wir haben es schliesslichgemeinsam gekauft.
Das ist richtig.
Und wir haben es zusammen abbezahlt.
Darum gehört es jetzt uns und nicht mehr der Bank.
Und das sind unsere beiden Autos.
Unser Auto ist das Gelbe
Das rote Auto gehört nicht
uns, sondern deinem Vater.
Das ist richtig. Aber das
müssen ja nicht alle wissen.
Du hast recht. Es ist mir
einfach so rausgerutscht.
Wir sind am Ende unserer Hausführung.
Das nächste Mal schauen wirdas Innere unseres Hauses an.
Und jetzt zeigen wir dir noch weitereBeispiele zum Thema Possessivpronomen.
Also bleib dran.
Bilde Sätze wie im folgenden Beispiel.
Du und Klavier
Das ist dein Klavier.
Ich und Klavier.
Das ist mein Klavier.
Bist du bereit für weitere Beispiele?
Los geht es.
Ich und Haus
Das ist mein Haus.
Du und Haus.
Das ist dein Haus.
Er und Haus
Das ist sein Haus.
Ich und Katze
Das ist meine Katze.
Du und Katze
Das ist deine Katze.
Er und Katze
Das ist seine Katze.
Ist das dein Buch?
Bitte entschuldige. Was hast du gesagt?
Ich habe dich gefragt, ob das dein Buch ist.
Das ist eine sehr spezielle Frage.
Schliesslich befinden wir uns in einer Bibliothek.
Natürlich ist das nicht mein Buch.
Oder sind das dort deine Bücher?
Nein das sind nicht meine Bücher.
Siehst du.
Ich glaube jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Gut haben wir das geklärt.
Dieser Meinung bin ich auch.
Na grossartig.
Hast du eineAhnung wo sich unser Auto befindet?
Du wolltest sagen, unsere Autos.
Sehr witzig.
Bist du nicht mit unserem Auto gefahren?
Warum fragst du?
Du bist mit dem Auto gefahren.Also hast du das Auto auch parkiert.
Da ist etwas Wahres dran.
Dann sag Bescheid, wenn du
unser Auto gefunden hast.
Guten Tag Herr Meier.
Guten Tag Herr Nachbar.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute?
Ist das nicht ein herrlicher Tag?
Perfekt um unsere Vorgärten
auf Vordermann zu bringen.
Apropos Vorgarten.
Ist das Ihr Hundehaufen auf meinem Rasen?
Selbstverständlich ist das nicht mein Hundehaufen.
Und wessen Hundehaufen ist es dann?
Das sieht mir ganz nach dem
Hundehaufen von meinem Hund aus.
Sie haben doch gesagt, das
sei nicht Ihr Hundehaufen.
Ist es auch nicht.
Das ist der Hundehaufen meines Hundes.
War das Video hilfreich für dich?
Schreib es in die Kommentare.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.